fresh off of calling locally here in los
angeles the chargers monday night week
four victory over the las vegas raiders
and my colleague from the nfl network
and the co-host of the moves to move the
sticks podcast himself daniel jeremiah
back here on the rich eisen show how you
doing dj i'm doing good rich not not a
lot of sleep uh with a delayed start
last night and a little traffic getting
out of there but it was it was a fun
game it was a fun night well i mean this
team this chargers team is definitely
just to the eye the naked eye just
sitting here watching a totally
different team than the one last year
and i'm wondering what you see with your
keen
all 22i daniel well i i tell you what it
should be a good lesson for people you
know when you're hiring a head coach and
sometimes you get hung up on offense or
defense
at the end of the day you want to hire
somebody that that brings leadership to
the table first and foremost that can
establish an identity for your team and
your organization
and brain staley happens to also just be
a fantastic defensive coach but that's
down the list for me of why that's been
such a home run higher when you see how
aggressive that they play
and the confidence that he has and then
he puts in his guys
um to me it's it's a game changer i've
seen you know i've watched this team you
know growing up all my life um and i've
seen so many games like last night you
know get away from them and you kind of
get that oh no here we go and uh and
brandon staley i mean even when it
started to go bad during the third
quarter he never took his foot off the
gas pedal um and it's it's a totally
different identity here for this for
this group yeah i had joey bosa on the
pre-game show for westwood one and we we
aired that interview right here on this
show uh yesterday and when i asked him
about you know
the chiefs game and what it meant to the
team he he mentioned i didn't even bring
up granite state he mentioned that
everything played out the way that coach
told us and i'm like well what do you
mean
and he basically said that coach walked
him through throughout the week we're
going to get up on him early they're
going to make a run and we have to
expect that and and and and obviously
stand our ground and and once we expect
it to come and that sounds simple i mean
that does sound like you could describe
many games in the nfl like that but you
could see that bosa was picking up what
the coach was putting down and the fact
that it played out that way only lends
to bomb the team together like that
and i found that a fascinating story dj
yeah i know i it is fascinating and it
just there's a belief there's a buy-in
and there's a lot of darn good players i
mean this roster is really really
talented um i was telling money as we
were kind of getting into the game as
he's calling the game i said you know
what normally i look down at the board
and i say okay man well this is uh you
know you've got keenan allen on this
corner like this is this that's the
match up in this game
but when i looked at you know kind of
where the raiders are defensively and
some of that's with some injuries that
they have
but i'm like man you've got jared cook's
a match-up nightmare in the passing game
eckler's a match-up nightmare you've got
williams and keenan um there's a lot of
different ways they can go with the
football and a lot of favorable matchups
and in a game where keenan and mike
didn't really have much production they
found a way with just their backs and
tight ends to go out there and beat a
really really good raider team well i
mean and so now the last two weeks
together the chargers are are now three
in one just like the raiders and just
like the broncos a game in front of the
chiefs but the most important thing for
them is that they're two-and-oh in
division including one on the road
against you would say the toughest team
in the division since they're the
two-time defending conference champs not
just the division champs
how how do you see this whole conference
playing out certainly with the chiefs
and the bills haven't added on sunday
night on nbc how do you see that i think
it's i think it's competitive rich but
when you look at those three teams right
so if you looked at uh the chiefs the
bills and the chargers look at the
ceiling that you have at the quarterback
position with those three guys i mean
you're talking about big strong athletic
big time play makers highly intelligent
and they're all just getting better i
mean that's why you got to be so fired
up about the nfl where it is right now
we've got young star players at those
positions and they're not star players
buried on bad teams they're they're with
good coaches with great talent around
them um and that's why man it's just i i
i've never felt better about the sport i
mean i know it's been the best product
going for a long time it's not just an
infomercial but i can't remember a time
we've had this many talented young
quarterbacks and this isn't matthew
stafford you know in detroit where
you're kind of like no no they were
going to be able to make the playoffs
these guys have great coaches and great
talent around them this is going to be a
fun decade so um throwing it out there
though you would place your chips where
because let's just throw the ravens who
are three in one despite going to the
the running back bargain basement store
right at the beginning of the season
and the browns sitting there at three
and one and the browns are the ones
coming in to take on the chargers and so
far in week five map it all out for me
what do you think yeah i think i think i
think you hit on it rich with those two
games this next week are going to be
good learning opportunities you know
when you see the chiefs and the bills
and then you see the browns and the
chargers
i think we're going to learn i'm
actually going to be like a pretty good
litmus test for these for these four
teams so um i know when i look at them
on paper
i believe more in the bills as a
complete team you know with their
defense pitching a couple shutouts
versus kansas city's defense who's got a
lot of holes in it um and then i look at
the browns man the defense is
unbelievable but you know kenny can the
offense keep pace can baker you know
take his game to the level that these
other three quarterbacks in that group
can so looking at it from you know big
picture right now i i would say it's
buffalo and the chargers is the more
complete teams um but man it's uh it's
going to be fun to watch those two games
this upcoming weekend daniel jeremiah
here on the rich eisen show okay and now
you got to throw sam darnold back in the
mix from that class right from that
quarterback class from dallas that baker
led my report rich i had i'd hit it
under my bed um it was under lock and
key i dusted it off it's back up on the
shelf okay
so um
now you got josh allen and lamar jackson
and sam darnold's back in that mix right
now how real are the panthers despite
their loss in dallas what do you think
about that yeah i mean i i'm uh i love
matt rule and i you know their defense
when you watched all their earlier games
um
this team flies around they're fast they
are explosive um and and you know sam's
playing at a high level no christian
mccaffrey so i'll give you know the
offense a little bit of a pass on on the
cowboy game that's you know you're
missing your best player but defensively
i can't unsee what i saw there as much
as i loved the panthers the cowboys went
right through them and they did it
whatever they wanted back through the
air zeke on the ground so
you know it's uh i think they're i think
they're a really good young emerging
team um i'm not quite so sure they're in
that upper upper echelon just yet daniel
jeremiah here on the rich eisen show
what is happening in chicago can you
tell me why matt neggy after justin
fields not only shows improvement comes
up with his first career win and also
shows that i get sacked nine times one
week i'm not broken as a quarterback i'm
not broken mentally i'm not broken
spiritually
i'm gonna come out and make some flash
throws that bears fans have been waiting
to see from the quarterback position and
then the coach who comes out and says
it's dalton's job once he's healthy
again
can you walk me through all that daniel
uh rich i i would love to uh if i
understood it i would do my best to
explain it to you um but i don't and and
you kind of took the words out of my
mouth because i feel like we've been
talking about these young quarterbacks
entering the league for a long time
together
and i i stick to my same tried and true
answer which is if i think they're
physically tough enough and mentally
tough enough let's let them get their
mistakes out let's let them play and
let's let them learn let's let them grow
um and i don't think there's any
question at all about justin field's
mental and physical toughness to be able
to you know work through some of these
rough patches man i saw a lot of good
when you watch that game the other day
ran the ball really well off play action
they were taking shots down the field
which is what he does really well he
throws a beautiful deep ball he can
drive it um haven't even really
incorporated his legs all that much
but they went out they're competitive
they won a football game they played
really well
so i i don't for the life of me
understand it i just don't i would love
to explain it to you but it makes no
sense and
you know we can look at all these young
quarterbacks i mean zack wilson
was really bad in some of those early
games this year but if you're a jets fan
you're watching that saying good let's
get these mistakes over with these are
all learning opportunities he's he's
keeping his head up i mean the kid show
come out last week and played great and
made some big time throws and there's
going to be terrible games littered
throughout this season
but you see it going somewhere
starting andy dalton doesn't lead
anywhere it takes you nowhere but you've
been in you know facilities you've been
in meeting rooms you've been in
front offices you've been all over the
place in this league before you're doing
what you're doing right here what could
it possibly be i mean what could it
possibly
be
uh uh uh you know you're because
everybody's like you know how this works
in our business that when things are
confusing you fill the void with all
sorts of crazy stuff like he wants to
show that if he's not calling the plays
he's calling the shots you know i i
don't know the guy
he's only come on this show and it's
been totally straightforward he's
terrific with the media and
but but it just makes no sense to me
that yes
we we've gotten him his reps in practice
with the ones he's getting in rhythm
he's won a game and he's made some great
throws but if andy dalton's bone bruise
is fine he's the one who's going against
max crosby in that defense that was all
over justin herbert in the monday
nighter like in vegas like is that
literally what we're going to see in
vegas next week
well i mean here are a couple things
number one i work with matt for a couple
years in philadelphia he's a good guy
right um so you know that i i can't
imagine a million years because he
wanted to show everybody he's got power
what i think there's a couple theories i
would have number one
you've got coaches who always operate on
the short term and general managers for
the most part operate with the long term
so a coach
can save my job in order to save my job
i've got to you know you know developing
a court young quarterback and maybe he's
not i don't think he's ready and we're
losing games
maybe that doesn't save my job so
there's some of that short-term thinking
there and it also could be
you know sometimes you can have an
over-belief in your in your system right
and the x's and o's and you know andy
dalton because of his just experience
level maybe our playbook is you know a
couple hundred pages bigger with andy
dalton which allows me the option to run
my entire offense whereas with justin as
with any rookie
it's a little more limiting but
i'll you know i'll go to my grave saying
and uh players not plays you know i give
me the best you go get you the best
coach i'll go get the best players and
i'll take my chances so what's your
evaluation of the uh afc east
quarterbacks we saw this weekend one
with a win and zach wilson his first
career one and then one with almost a
win in the game that was one of the most
watched regular season games and of
interest because it was tom brady who
was trying to match uh point for point
on sunday night let's start with zach
what'd you think of
gym yeah it's by far his by far his best
performance i thought it's amazing what
happens when you get a little bit of
help up front with the offensive line
that was the best they had played up
front um so he had a little bit of time
and then even when he didn't have time
he showed you the ability to extend and
create i thought jamison crowder being
out there helped him um just having
another veteran he knew where he was
going to be it was no no
miscommunication
he's got he's just you know you saw the
default i mean he's got rare rare talent
i mean the ceiling for this kid is
ridiculously high um but again you're
going to live you're going to live with
some of the the bumps along the way but
that was a game as a jets fan which i
think you can dream on and say okay man
imagine once we get this offensive line
you know hopefully you get becked in
back and continue to draft and add guys
to that that front and we had more
playmakers around him um this guy's got
a chance to be really really good i
thought after the game i don't know if
he saw it but his post game you know one
of the first things he said was you know
hey look i should have ended this thing
in regulation i got to be better you
know i had an opportunity there to get
that done and i didn't do it so he
understands that he's got a lot of a lot
of room and space to grow um but i
thought that was the way i would put it
you know it's a game you can dream on
when you see some of the things that kid
can do and what about mac jones it seems
like he is the perfect vessel for what
the patriots want to do with the short
passing game that we saw for all those
years
with tom brady uh what do you what do
you make of mac jones's first month in
the nfl yeah you know he's he he's look
he's kind of been as advertised right
he's been a really good decision maker
he's been very accurate but rich you
can't it's such a tight rope that
they're walking with the way they're
playing when you don't have any
explosives when you when you only throw
the ball over 15 yards once and it gets
picked off
you can set all the completion records
you want um but they don't they don't
put completion numbers up on the
scoreboard they put points up there so
they have got to find a way to be more
explosive and i i don't know if they
have that personnel on their roster
right now but if you are in a situation
where you can't run the ball and you
can't push the ball vertically down the
field um it's just your defense is going
to have to play like they did the other
night just play lights out um and you're
going to find yourself winning a bunch
of 13 10 type games
i just don't know if that's
you know i think about i talk about zach
wilson and i can dream on where they can
go now they aren't as they aren't as
efficient uh as the patriots but they
have the upside to
to be really good eventually i don't
know that this patriots offense the way
it's set up um but the way they're
playing if they have the upside to to be
really good i just i don't see it
there's no explosive plays and you got
to have them you can't win games if you
can't get explosive plays so um
what what's the answer um is it
um you know nikhil harry now that he's
back off the ir nelson aguilar can take
the top of the defense off take your
shots because uh the deep balls were
mostly thrown on sunday night off the
trick plays
that's what you saw in that game
yeah you're trying to manufacture it's
just a tough way to live i to me it's
two things number one they've got to get
faster they don't have a real fast team
so they've got to get they've they've
got to do something in the offices now
look at mac what he did at alabama
they were able to get plenty of deep
shots and vertical shots you can do that
when you've got waddle and davonte smith
out there um so they've got to give him
some speed next year um and the other
thing is you get deep shots in the nfl
you know when you have some threat of a
run game um and you can pull those
safeties and scare those safeties down a
little bit when you can't run the ball a
lick
you don't get that luxury so
those are the two things they're gonna
have to get better at um so that was my
thing i think from a baseball analogy
um you know that that would be zach
would be kind of the four four five with
four singles and then
you go okay that's fantastic but then
zach wilson can go one for five with a
three-run home run and then you can have
the debate of who impacted the game more
last one for you daniel jeremiah i guess
in between quarters one and two of this
uh coming weekend week five of this now
17-game regular season will be the
actual real quarter post mark normally
it's right now
where after four games are in the book
still weird
i know like but you know but we in the
media we're we're kind of confused it's
kind of the way i open the show in a way
we're kind of confused uh as to when
this quarter post is i think we've hit
it so
if we already have
um
the fact that the cardinals are 4-0 in
the last remaining undefeated team in
the league are they the best team in the
league you mentioned speed earlier about
the importance of speed and the
importance of putting up points and
splash plays my gosh do they have that
uh big time uh the cowboys just kind of
do too man i mean they've got some kids
flashing on that defense in the front
and the back end
what do you make of the best team in the
league right now at this point
daniel well yeah i mean look the
cardinals are undefeated and they've got
some quality wins i think to me the
thing about them that stands out the
most is that you know tennessee coming
to the season we would have said you
know one of the three most physical
teams in the nfl
the cardinals went in there and beat him
up the rams you know are really really
good team with the you know returning
with the best defense in the nfl and
they beat them up um i didn't have that
on my uh on my card that you'd have the
cardinals coming out and being this
physical team so
yeah i mean they're undefeated they've
got quality wins and they've won at the
line of scrimmage i think if you're
going to say right now take a snapshot
of it
you have to say they're the best team
but i know one thing the uh
the best the demo field uh participant
i've seen in the national football
league this year is the guy i'm talking
to on the phone
dude you know those demos you know i go
out there and they're like all right
you're the you're you're the guard and
you walk down the field or you're the
linebacker you creep up and i'm like all
right you you know like and then i take
two steps and then i two take two steps
back and i'm all i can just be is who i
am and i just know one speed daniel as
you know you know that's why it
frustrated me because i didn't realize
that you were available i thought you
might have been on the injured list or
something because i did one demo earlier
this year
and i was given the instructions and uh
and you were not uh labeled as a
participant correct demo so i was i was
a little baffled that you you know that
the health situation was where it needed
to be in my demo but then i turn it on
the next week and i've got you playing
multiple positions i mean
not only not only a participant but
somebody that's being used like a derwin
james type role where you're down the
box one play and you're playing high on
the next i mean i don't get it you know
what daniel um i'm just trying to do my
job you know uh be that uh swiss army
knife
that uh i can be not only as a host of a
show but on the demo field but so next
time are you going to be coming in this
time because it's it's a well actually
this week we're off we're off this week
two weeks okay all right so i'll be back
i'll be back in there so i want to see
this for myself you know sometimes they
say it's important to do scouting in
persons right uh i need to see that for
myself last thing before i go rich yes i
always tell you where i do these
interviews yes sir today where are you i
am at a triple threat it is a gas
station that also has a car wash that
also has a little mexican restaurant
shop right inside of it it's a briefer
wait a minute the is the mexican
restaurant is not in the car wash is it
no it's inside the gas station okay
which also has the cars you can
literally pump some gas go order your
rolled tacos then get it back in your
car go through the car wash pick up your
old tacos and off you go it's a 3-4
interesting incredible video and if you
wait long enough you might be able to go
through the the you know ask for the
bathroom key as well
i'm assuming you can do all four of
those things potentially god bless yeah
it could be a quadruple three bathroom
i'm not going to visit but i'll take
your word well done daniel well
obviously as always take a photograph
and we'll post it on our twitter feed
please do got you take care thanks dj
daniel jeremiah at move the sticks right
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here